what some food podcast what's our full
podcast welcome everybody who listen to
the whirlpool podcast and everybody out
there who just say they litter too but
they don't really think to it they just
share it
thank you for sharing also what's up man
we might get off the air people we might
like this might be one of our last
podcast we ever do because um
nobody's I'm sharing it actually and
nobody's actually writing down sending
those iTune person knows and saying how
great the show is kind of tired of doing
it now bro you know what I mean
everybody was so there for free I'm
tired they really think we top it it's
up to you but I was going whatever dude
is YouTube mess with algorithms you
trying to make people share it you throw
that venmo up online money will start
flowing well right now has one patron
the patreon and like they do I they do
special episodes
we're like some people were like you
know he's trying to get a motorcycle huh
no yeah he fell off oh you got so skinny
no eating candy like how much candy are
you eating
get back real skinny man they knew what
happened bro ah stop eating cheese
cheese
Yeah right we know what's up fool we
have Becky Robinson in the house people
yell over morning and I made extra time
to put makeup on this the Jazz face so
always always happy when it's uh you
know yeah the cameras are right here
yeah guys mostly guys sure you all be on
the chat up here you know it's funny man
like what like we're gonna that's that's
how the the jazz station always starts
you know unreal and the lay station like
every time I go to suggest a [ __ ]
yeah man we're gonna we're gonna need
people to start doing any money yeah
yeah he - it's a little sound for a song
to have the Jazz tour we're gonna stop
in five stops for jazz it's two people
who keep us on here we don't need no
money left for the podcast we're doing
fine we just need people to start like
be more active you know like if you like
the podcast huh so you need some gel
razors make sure the Rena Marie yeah
hey you brought my spirits Allah Allah
Allah
Tino still don't know what a podcast is
that we're all doing a show showing I
told this guy well yeah I'm also on the
Felipa podcast and I was trying to
download what's they call it spot like I
was trying to just find the thing on is
the podcast being on his phone he say
hey man you know I don't want them to
charge me like no bro people's iPhones
and let me see your iPhone yeah podcast
app Spotify iTunes if you got it or
Google Play or some what's the one song
Rodrigo and now Marcin really have a
Spanish podcast podcast Raziel not the
yeah we were first good there was gonna
be some legal difficulties so we talked
to the Mexican guys with the hats and
the boots and they said it's alright
yeah and they'll send us a little shiny
jacket we will find that podcast I know
right now just don't Spotify that
Spotify it's on Google podcast Bricker
radio public we're gonna do that through
anchor Africa we're gonna do we're not
gonna do a free service as of today
tonight or tomorrow and then it'll be
available on all platforms okay Tom
Segura this by this podcast ambien oh
really
yeah yeah announced elated by himself
how many pockets do you have there's too
many
I'm exhausted he has one with Bert
Kreischer called the bears bear in the
cave or someone with me might think of
the what's up a stop vodka
what so Russell Martin would end right
here Felipe Esparza talking all talking
each other and couldn't be further off
the recommendation if there's not enough
time fool it's not enough time
like dude oh my god but I wasn't saying
I get making Robertson just start a
podcast right now bacon fell we did a
show together I remember where yeah we
were in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
well that is right where it was a Navy
base was it maybe or an army base or
something yeah Mitchell oh yeah she uh
she she came in because that was in
there yeah that do want to go open up
for another comedian
no no Ricky he's for me because he'll
burn up like that thank you very much
I forget that one guy did a little
one-nighter those fun
faces are in the middle of nowhere like
every airport every reason we're too
late look I knew was gonna be like a
different Corral and like what is gonna
not like yeah they're all like in their
late like it's like they gave them jobs
because no one else to hire them you
know here the base reserves outside one
of the people after I went to go eat
something after the show and it was one
of those like one of snack bars you see
like when you travel by Greyhound you
know yeah yeah they make up a new dose
yeah
so that guy was telling me that he was
taking um he took a lot of photos during
like the Gulf War like he was in battle
just taking photos the pole a bunch of
us yeah Vietnam also and the Philippines
but I'm just waiting for my cheeseburger
you were waiting yeah didn't you find a
bunch of weed it out after that show oh
that was that one oh finesse Mitchell he
spoke to a guy who was a janitor there
who was not from the base and he would
he left the base and then came back yeah
that's called a connect right there yeah
I was a hockey
was a veteran there very few people who
are not part of the like they work on
base who aren't part of military yeah
yeah his mom was a veteran yeah they're
all better his whole family
and he got a job because family works
there you have a job with good benefits
whole life
Wow nepotism that's the dream right
there it was in the middle of nowhere
bro Fort Huachuca yeah remember renting
a car and driving out there and then
like they go to check your ID and
there's just rifles all over the place
and you're like oh [ __ ] what do I
accidentally have on me security to get
in there I'll add security what do once
the killer out there they went to
another one in law booth and then
somebody came in damn and then when they
checked is there another one that was
three of them against so you guys did a
bunch of those shows yes we have for
this Mitchell here and I forgot that my
opponent I made fun of one of the guys
there and everybody laughed he had like
this and I see this lady still
camouflage to left because they were in
the same clothing we're on a plane yeah
what was he losing white skin or no did
everything broke even if a white person
gets it they even get wider than yeah
when it was black person saw puzzle yeah
you don't you're not wise
bro he was like a do I lean TAFIa
chocolate it's like half chocolate half
yeah do I lean it's like something a red
paste or something on a spoon holding a
spoon and it's wrapped with saran wrap
around it's like your mom made it to the
convenience stores yeah it's weird it's
like Nutella Nutella spread I don't know
how they make it
what's up fool podcast people start now
see my upcoming shows now before people
turn now this Friday December 6th at
Grand Prairie Texas at the Verizon
theater but DeRay Davis cocoa brown
faizon love and Felipe Esparza Marlon
Wayans the community a lighter lighter
and I was some fool we're talking about
Riverside California December 10 the off
Spanish show at life's Art Center
bureau's cheese days Portland Oregon
December 30th Revolution Hall the Iguana
Mexico and this is here to Diciembre
December 17 antigua bodega de papel or
spanish or enjoy spirals that might be
at that show doing a meet-and-greet in a
pickpocket after the show can take the
podcast equipment over there right no
brother let's try to do that yeah my
brother's well Santa Ynez California
Chumash casino December 20 Victorville
California December 22nd our spanish
show at the Holiday Inn with Peter Lois
ah no no I saw Peter Peter Phoenix
Arizona December 27th or 31st and of
live Phoenix Jeff shows coming up yeah
Thank You Robinson
this is alive right yeah nice okay this
just this weekend December 8 Gotham New
York 6 p.m. show it's my new character
show it's [ __ ] buckwild please come
out if you're in New York or
Poughkeepsie bring the family it's gonna
be insane
listen filming out there December 17th
Los Angeles UCB Franklin and doing the
show again December 19 to 20 second with
Pete Lee at Bray improv this January
16th at Bray Improv I'll be headlining
Bray improv that one and then January
17th 18th I'll be in Lincoln Nebraska at
the comedy lost come on out let's drink
some Hot Buttered Rum butter beer yeah
what's your favorite character you do
Becky Suzy chapstick but depends on the
day some days if I'm feeling a little
frantic I'd like to do Alan Gingrich
who's like for right now yes Suzy
chapstick I'm it cuz it's winter and
she's a coked-out skier so it's like
just the most fun for me were you from a
tiger Dorgan so Portland that's where I
think oh that is from what the high
school there yeah I went to Tigard high
yeah yeah yeah that's high school yeah
[Laughter]
he graduated like 88 yeah yeah before my
time when I go home I was just home in
Portland and I did a show over the
weekend and like all the teachers come
out from high school and it's just it's
weird at first I was like this is creepy
but they're they're all so cool but like
it's like we're over 18 now you know and
they're like what's up your sex jokes
and you're like god dammit
[ __ ] say that to me in front of my
father but my makeups yeah whatever
thank you they need me up pool with one
of my professors one time it was a
professor though partner I still felt
weird known pool at a bar and it was
like this is so strange
this was my professor it's like here's
my freshmen I saw my team I saw him I
think when I was a sophomore I saw my
teacher Miss I do ho
she was my suit my homeroom teacher and
my English teacher she's the one that
taught her how to make a commercial yeah
yeah we're about to go make a commercial
like in a radio and now that I would say
pay attention to the whole class dog but
I was there every day so not paying
attention I wasn't a girl who never
showed up you know every day we used to
every day brother I missed one day I
never recovered seems to be a girl that
will come in but he should do a care
about this [ __ ] man yeah this chick
will cover it
partied out bro she want to be like 40
or 50 mine in 10th grade she will come
in like and I'm sure we right before us
know from the from the party at 6:00 in
the morning somewhere at a park with a
19 year old him beers monetary if you're
smoking weed and then she was look at
her like all badass my friend will be
like low did you party already
and she was like she was wearing like a
corduroy Levi jacket with fur and like
Marcus in Native American moccasin that
should be like that I wasn't when I was
told a bottle cap from her 40 on sir the
Fuuka smelly dog should keep the bottle
cap and just flick it at somebody bro
the hell they were in our class she
should like we were there really like
two three weeks here in the class and
she'll barely getting her books are late
now you know they [ __ ] you in a fail
dog yeah but I am they're fairly - so I
have to make a commercial or other
winner throw the class is this high
school high school what
so our teacher was English but she was
too hardcore and she got off the she did
whatever she wanted me visual urges
audio no just English audio out with
audio okay so we had to make a cell make
up a product write a paper on it
Holloway is in the paper then to the
commercial lift up with for what you're
gonna say so it were to my house yeah my
friends house Rafa Murad and jorge
vasquez and then there for pornos yeah
you worked at my high school made up a
story coffee made up a story called
musician remember sort of called Bobo up
like this order they make you burp
commercial no jingle without 22 we are
without without [ __ ] up 20th Century
Fox music everybody want to hear it
again what that teacher was I never
thought that I was cool because of that
I wanted to tell her that but she was
she was getting on a plane
bro I was getting off the plane broad
creep the [ __ ] out of her bro to the
word through her life but she thought I
was just one of those do that though the
pervert if you're a teacher you should
be on your toes and kind of know who the
[ __ ] was in your class with ice cream to
approach people crazy though like when
you saw Audrey Plaza at the pumpkin
patch and you said I'm reporter director
from Nickelodeon it's cute on her nature
though her dad Celine know Carly
Cosgrove concert
actual names have you ever accidentally
called a celebrity by their Instagram
handle that's real embarrassing do you
guys have any teachers you guys had it
on social media friend requests and you
add them I always deny am I never had a
teacher requests me oh wait one teacher
who I do follow and he follows me he's
insane he's my old social studies
history teacher guy yeah I get a lot of
dams for mine oh yeah did you study
sports teachers that I like would be
their TA or whatever and I'd go get him
lunch they'd be like you can skip the
rest or whatever they were always cool
but one of them yeah one of them my
sister got really obsessed with spray
tanning her like sophomore year like
bright you know she was orange she would
write these fake notes and then she
would walk to the tanning salon and skip
PE and finally this one coach found out
and I called our parents and now he sees
our parents I like every show and we
always have a good little laugh about it
because he's like at the time he was
like your daughter is just never gonna
make it in life we're doing this [ __ ]
skipping class going tanning [ __ ] wants
to bronze up you know do a water down
what you were watering out what I was on
well now yes I didn't told me that what
you're a man huh I know we were on the
show one season how was that like I was
wild that work it's so much work I felt
like I never slept
there's not many there's like two girls
on the show so we got a lot of episodes
which was awesome but it was like yeah
you shoot two three episodes a day and
there's a bad episode and you do your
own writing
do you writers like
like that rapture those people don't do
any writing on that shut not the talent
oh yeah no I had known it was my first
kind of like sketch TV TV show
did he TV show and uh yeah it was a lot
I was overwhelmed a lot I left a lot of
days I was scared I didn't know like I
you know I was like this white girl on
the show and I like when it came time to
battle rap like people got so [ __ ]
aggressive grab the mic from you and I
just like I didn't know I was like okay
I got it and then one day luenell
you know luenell yeah sure she's been a
missile yeah she came up to me and she
was like that you better get your stage
time and after that I was like okay
you're right you're right you're right a
lot of alpha males huh yes but it was
cool yeah like Nick was never gonna come
up and like walk me through it and be
like you gotta be aggressive so it was
really nice that she did that cuz it
made me buck up and stop being such a
little puss well cuz she's dealt with
that same testosterone factor at those
shows and she's got to be the one to
stand out and she goes out and owns that
stage yeah yeah like she said I'd do my
time and I'm out and like she's
respected up there yeah it was a so fun
though like just the music and dancing
and energy all day every day it was cool
cool then I saw with you what who was
going to show you Michael Blackson
blacks and did a bunch of episodes
Chico bean DC young fly right right hole
comes on there's a boy yo bro it was
going on the Bonnie
I mean Becky yeah I got a lot of hug
your name's Becky shut the [ __ ] up you
know cuz we have muffled call you Beth
a lot of fun guest T I was awesome uh
Azalea yeah it was really funny Jake
Allen no no no okay
sure damn belt he wore denim pants a
wild and out t-shirt and a blue blazer
denim like that leg is cheap I guess huh
denim I thought you wear the denim shirt
and denim have phantom [ __ ] Roy
Rogers Herbert Lincoln yeah I think
that's his relaxed look about you are
not relaxed oh no I hate them I don't
understand that my brother were used to
wear the leather braided belt as part in
the shorts like that was his weekend
we're like hey that's relaxed let's with
dress shoes what was your first
character they ever did ever ever
oh god like when you realized like and
how old were you were like when you
realize you could do stuff like that
young I saw I was obsessed with Austin
Powers so I used to always impersonate
Fat Bastard when I was a kid yeah and
then like my first one was I think in
college we made this little web series
called LaMarcus and Gentry and I was
Jean tree and when I first started
stand-up that was my stage name people
were there haiji tree and I wore like
this massive blonde wig and sometimes I
wear this little baby blue do-rag yeah
and then from there yeah they just yes
spiral just kept going kept buying wigs
and now I have way too many are all your
characters original you do still
impersonate anybody like everything's
original I don't love doing impressions
but if I did I did I did woke Hillary
Clinton for a while had a good run I
just have seven pant suits now
collecting dust in my closet I make a
comeback she might I know I love her
because when she would do the debate she
was so stiff so I would go clubbing at
night as Hillary I got everything I got
free bottle service for [ __ ] months
sorted pained me to go do it to like
vote for Hillary caja you know so I
would like [ __ ] pop on a handstand as
hell that's why she lost
yeah so now I do i do Tiffani Trump I
feel like she's just like neglected
second daughter like people can kind of
empathize with her and you don't really
have to make it political one way or the
other it's just like to crumpet yeah
Marla maples by Marla yeah where's you
got shows coming up yes
next week the tenth and Riverside with
you guys and then the 11th at laquida
and Boyle Heights and then pour them
with you and ever again I'm doing a Toys
for Tots the week after then oh yeah I'm
doing a couple of those Toys for Tots
for who for I can't a mummy for the
mummies for the kids was a cute Walter
Reyes
Oh watch out ray yeah wait again he lost
weight yeah he lost weight a while ago
and then it became a real estate agent
right yeah yeah and then after that I
think he tried get a comedian to be like
a man if you help me sell houses I'll
give you money
yeah what are you writing a check to
right now something he's doing afterward
the reminder hose yeah but I have a
little
Doudna show the Latino bar association
tomorrow did in Riverside County I think
I've ever performed there never it's
cool it's chill desert suburban yeah
it's Riverside on the way to Palm
Springs yeah yeah actually the pit stop
to Palm Springs for the stars back in
the day of the it's right before the
freeway takes up The Birth of a Nation
and gone with the winds world premiere
we're at the Fox Theater there in the
beautiful downtown yeah man the kid had
to let the Riverside downtown had they
just lit their their lights families to
hang out and walk the hotel really nice
the mission in really really old school
and like different entrance for Mexicans
only no we used to watch Mario LaMotta
movies back in the Lola Latrell era can
go if you go out to the alley there were
stairs there that changes to the balcony
because that's what everybody said the
one in Highland Park to that had the
four dollar movies Highland Park theater
don't figure on yeah yeah yeah how many
seats is Fox Theater which one they bury
in Riverside it's like 1600 I think
something like that yeah can I just feel
how many 2018 Bakersfield
Sasa 800 ah Bakersfield was bigger it
was like 1,500 I want to say 1,400
good-sized pretty good size
that's or somebody didn't at all due to
the Fresno has a fox - right
I say leah has a Fox and that is
Fresno's tower you know Fox Visalia I
think that's around nine in Sacramento
yeah well suck how much do they have the
crest theater and the Tower Theater
other small yeah yeah Chris Theatre was
no okay no I can't remember how much
crest theater was worthy 14 where the
Fox Theater zone
Fox yeah originally yeah a Sly Fox show
movies like they own their own places
where soft voice - what you watch on
that flavor right now the Irishman
always if you're watching that story of
a post catalog regular C Wrigley yeah
we're talking these on there not yet
the guy who [ __ ] me fro their food Oh
burgers I first met frozen vegetables ya
Bob Cassidy the Rizzo that hit the fan
are still keeping everyone cool Oh Pongo
fans
no no palm string fans remember how I
that was our fans to keep the people
cool oh that's right the windmills
after all that what did you get - I'm
blending in movies pilots
hello movies hello party videos no I
some stuff after a little bit I made two
pilots with NBC we were trying to make
like a female Ali G show but with E
which was and just that was like yeah
this is never gonna work
this needs to be somewhere else because
that's you know home of the Kardashians
and stuff and it's it's we're taking it
elsewhere now actually yeah I want to do
a female character show there's like
there were so you know I grew up
watching like jackass and Punk'd and all
that [ __ ] and like guys watching it and
it's like I want girls to be able to
watch a girl do that stuff - will you
ever know Tracey Ullman yeah I got kids
in the hall but not as much me that's -
Monty Python is for me I'm not in my
honey pie dude's face
[Music]
you know it's you know what even if you
don't like kids in the hall though that
movie brain candy that they did was
[ __ ] funny yeah they're so funny oh
it's a good we go what did you see it's
funny the movies fun it's a hard candy
no Lucy honey boy yet no but I want to I
think my mother's like like that guy
what's your honey boy loosely based off
Shia LaBeouf's life sure plays a version
of his father and about like his life
going through like showbiz as a kid
really that's one the Byron Bauer is in
right yes his girlfriend directed that
okay Byron Bauer his girlfriend yeah
she's Israeli and she's done a lot of
otago stuff but I wanted that's what
Deborah was telling us yes yeah love
Shia used born in LA right he's from
Iowa like bearings oh yeah no I sit by
him Bowers Oh Scientologists too or no
no we're Scientology's right no I'm
really asthma Tyrion
no I got turned into Mormon Joe's
witness Maya I told you guys my men are
Jehovah's Witness friends yeah turn into
a Mormon or Jehovah's Witness and he was
I got baptized in something I got
baptized in a pool you don't even know
the Mormon Church yeah how long ago like
10 years ago
oh wow she told me if I didn't give it
away and then but he never married her
and we broke up exactly yeah they just
do that too so now they're stuck this is
the one that has the mom as the hoarder
no no no another one no that was not ten
years ago
that's crazy boy your mom let you do
that she's an intelligent man [ __ ]
Jehovah's Witness that's funny
she got me that one I they're very
different religion yeah yeah just before
you got with ghetto chicks yeah you guys
start having sex after you got baptized
no you're having sex before that yeah oh
she was thinking oh is this gonna be the
guy I married
yeah yeah yeah
then she joined a car club in [ __ ]
Ontario of course I'm not a Mormon and
ignore nest or Mormon with the movie
theater oh yeah no you're these
listeners remember every [ __ ] stories
that's like your first episode you
mentioned that guards second I talk
about the me to being that guy at the
movie theater is like he tried to touch
remember and I know I do
the movie theaters we're talk about the
meat - yeah yeah and some guy used to
work with he was like we're cleaning
with there alone in the corner you're
trying to touch me and they're like you
got look at me Pleiades up hands and his
dick was like movie in the pants and I
[ __ ] soccer-mom the pulsating again
he gives young kids money right no no he
got fired because he what's it called
oh girl owning the theater for that [ __ ]
he got fired because it girls banging
over and he pinched her a salut was
coming you don't know what the [ __ ] you
want it bro you just wanted he just
wants something
from tamale puzzle fools from a hammer
bro an action straight from Mexico
Mexican like that camera hmm Nestor who
remembers these fans are crazy
detected yourself oh I saw that's like I
was like 19 you give them the one tools
[ __ ] what I learned from the Rocky
movies bro yeah these are hardcore fans
I can't believe it's only a floor
tickets we could get Laker floor seats
they're just they're crazy expensive and
all those celebrities would have them by
the way don't pay for their tip their
seats
I feel like it's a bit of pressure to to
come up with the fit oh yeah quartz is
certain outfit you know you got to make
sure you know what you're gonna how
you're gonna position yourself what are
you gonna drink what are you gonna be it
can be going over there without and then
big ole nachos are sloppy husband you
know hemorrhoid I'm so glad you brought
that up I was just inside you Lita for a
wedding and my ass has not been right
ever since I see I mean the Montezuma's
didn't hit for a while I he's been in
Sayulita
know I've got a hammer me too
so wait you're saying food like food
poisoning or water the like almost don't
even I don't think they have like sewage
proper sewage so there's like [ __ ]
everywhere dumping out into the ocean
it's in the water so if you accidentally
slurp a little something like you're
gonna be [ __ ] for weeks and I'm
still bouncing back and come over
exertion right yeah
I had to go over there straight to Aspen
for shows and like I don't know if it
was the altitude that [ __ ] him up more
or what but you better sit on a snowball
[Laughter]
they were like moguls coming out of my
ass I looked at I looked at my right I
didn't know it was just a pole pushed it
in with the colon that comes out as
blood vessels that's very different the
year what time what would I ate the last
time but went to the bathroom brother
and I when I wipe it was just [ __ ] it
like blood right because relief didn't
know that we're gonna hurt afterwards
right man it came out final happy stinks
but they when I went to the bathroom
again bro I felt like I was raped by a
ghost hours ago I was sodomized bro like
their nest and I saw Pacino was going
crazy
I heard you paint houses no totally
anti-gay I watch people think the punk
rock scene or the heavy metal scene was
crazy that scene was crazy that was that
was that giving of leather and chains I
guess yeah it was so hot yeah like the
game when Queen when Freddy Mercury kind
of started coming out even though he
always called himself bisexual when he
started coming out it was
huh yeah you know it's crazy to when
homeboy was tough before he came out of
the closet Jew Judas Priest was all
leather don't like that looking at
midnight don't always go with that
yeah that's sometimes it's just a tough
guy there they feel like a tough guy and
I think you were saying
rocky guys more transsexuals crisis
freeze remember Jews presents festival
man house on the bass players shoulders
bro 1978 bro was in [ __ ] New Jersey
with um Carlos you don't know [ __ ]
music
that's great gosh [ __ ] I wasn't
there I was in the [ __ ] Judas Priest
bro you know what bro supposed to go to
that concert
that was the day room in Los Angeles
next to my cousin's ball yeah learn
about that bar cup it was crazy
yeah it went all the way to [ __ ] uh
where you from [ __ ]
Yosemite [ __ ] right there you send me
right there with a long so I sit man
wait a minute no I wasn't that was the
one day I'm not with you
how do you come up with material for
your characters to do on stage because
you take these characters on stage right
you know the whole stage act yeah does
it work like a one-woman show
it is now okay I truly was just like
unhappy with the hour I was doing on the
road so I was like let me try mixing
some [ __ ] up cuz we can do whatever we
want you know you forget like it's
different basically like you could do
two different sets or three different
sets in one mm-hmm all different
characters yeah there's there's one that
the ski want Suzy chapstick I started
doing because I realized and then it got
a little scary because I liked I could
do my material as her and I would say it
more intensely like I believed in it
more and I like didn't give a [ __ ] and
then I got scared to go back to being
myself like I don't know I haven't
watched Frankie Ken Jana is go like do
his life either behind to see that
though cuz like do you change on stage
like are you dressed in layers and you
yeah because it depends either the
lights will black out and all like shed
a layer or they'll be like a video in
between and all like just change that
backstage really quickly I don't really
care people see my ass on stage
sometimes I just change on stage that
like are you yourself then and those
in-between moments sometimes
yeah about that sometimes I do a little
bit of myself and sometimes I don't
there's a little bit of me and all the
characters though if that makes sense
uh yeah but they all have kind of
different outlooks on life but they're
all kind of like deep down lovable
losers who just want to be you know
accepted you're like gonna go to the
rail morning radio as a character and
the character mm-hmm and what do the
people say the radio guy do you know who
you are sometimes I make I bring an
extra wig and I make the radio guy put
it on too
they go with it there's your podcast
with your characters talking to each
other that's that's part you working on
you've been off - off the hook comedy
club yeah
dr. Brian the car comedians and [ __ ]
come on die getting coffee but did a
podcast podcast in the cars
you're a national tour in Naples what
what I do the podcast car oh I didn't
have to do that I got surprised well I
wouldn't know
he's taking me the radio and other
things I was doing radio he starts a
podcast in his car a little camera
there's a little camera fool and it's
plain and they had a low light behind
him like a little low light behind you
allowed this ambush that's not it was
called a captain log podcast right yeah
I was there Oh Johnny yeah yeah right
yeah well we did agree to a podcast but
he never told us it was in the car but
if we're not getting podcast we're
getting fish there occasionally podcast
that you do not fit here there's old
vodka Mel right Morton or captain I
forget what Bryce he's got his own line
of actually the several different
out-and-out dressings yeah that comedy a
lot of different ideas wait why cuz this
podcast popped offers no no just do it
oh he just has different streams of in
the shuffle the money over there like a
[ __ ] on the food at that Club I
am obsessed with like the seafood pastas
or I get on stage and I'm just the mac
and cheese oh man
yeah yeah yeah have you had the
swordfish I have not have to search fish
but have you been fishing with him have
you been fishing yeah did you come back
oh yeah I went on a boat with some guys
I met at that Club had a hilt I'm but uh
not with Captain Brian I wonder what
kind of boat he's got yeah carry as a
woman like finishing a show and then
hanging out with friends and with fans I
definitely take too many risks yeah and
get really drunk but because I'd be
worried more as a woman than a guy and I
think about with fans the work that
happened to you getting drugged with
these fans what's the worst thing that's
happened getting oh I don't know too
much stolen wig like maybe me ending up
wanting to hook up with a guy that
didn't have a condom
kameena said to have a dream of the
ovary katana breath will put off he got
a [ __ ] sandwich bag and he put a
rubber band on their dog and that girl
said all right
that [ __ ] up from the inside
[Music]
hemorrhoids raised that big first people
use like saran wrap yeah I just I heard
about this I wrap doesn't work don't let
something do that yeah dental dam
imagine a put that little fruit roll-up
bro yeah
yeah didn't block anything but the guy
what's-his-face Benjy from the Howard
Stern Show no no he is a cookie rapper I
think it was go down I hate to go down
on a stripper at a bachelor party and I
like why women what pleasure do you get
out of it everybody laughing I guess
yeah he just wants to be shot I went to
a bachelor party where they all dip
their little lucky charms pop and then
hand it off to all the guys and
everybody's all sucking on them what was
this fondue party after ten blow jobs
that go down in 15 some fools dad goes
whoever wants to get blown I got [ __ ]
gotchas Mario you have to drop that that
is gross that's crazy that's funny I'll
just figure it out amen where they get
buggy points yeah are you gonna get a
[ __ ] from somebody who's given ten
already lovely partner and a [ __ ] to
get him out [ __ ] for 20 bucks like
she was passing those out and then she
gave out the menu of chart and after ten
the Helen back were they black seen in
that house I kept my 60 bucks whatever
when I had the opportunity show was gay
bro and for Lee twins they were called
Burt and Al over there named Al and Burt
and their sister or dirty-ass cousin who
literally Roger
she was the she was the best [ __ ] of
the year my cousin's over there bro lady
cuz they're not their birthday and they
want and they're like she said she's
stupid man she was while she was hitting
a ball
Bob she was a our video were the
horrible one brought debutantes the
dirtied every time he had the dirty J
Betar and powers the favorite black side
um that guy Alan Bert took me in Gabriel
is just to his back and his girls are
hitting a ball broke keep in mind I
wasn't even smoking weed back then I
wasn't straight edge but I wasn't doing
on nasty [ __ ] like that like smoking
weed or drinking beer you know me hey
bro doing nothing either bro nothing so
they asked us I'm a man I how about if I
blow ball for you guys and then my
cousin don't have to pay you for the
comedy show like this is how guys lose
their performance money yeah I don't
know nothing you like we didn't make
that much I mother ate five car that's
not a talk with Bill I check our
reinstalling a two-liter for soda bro
rules I know I came in I put a two liter
and I put in the car I came back taking
[ __ ] from the house they told me
whatever you want to eat it'll kind of
sound that bro [ __ ] chicken bro
hamburgers so I made like a big burrito
carne asada and then I made broke ego
you want see some home can i yeah can I
make my own plate brought me one plate
it was a very big closed approaches just
me and the other one tortillas and I
said I'm thirsty you want some soda yeah
that's what a two liter brother put and
then this [ __ ] freak shows up bro in
a garage I'm [ __ ] heartburn for a
burrito right so then yeah bro she has
out blows over the year and like that
bro like Joey knows how she does it yes
we kept our 60 bucks and our honor
imagine we talked about that story for
years it was like $100 when we kept the
honey buzz bro
then we left right or money
Becky Robertson sex drive system you
ever had a guy promoting well you know
what Becky man everybody's got a room
say you you got to share with me oh no
oh yeah you get comics on the road
luenell had somebody who paid for the
room and set her up and then he was in
the room oh hell man he'll [ __ ] no
fly solo to a show and when he got into
a room here a bag he retired or that
Mexican dude they're ironing what are
you doing here homie oh man but DJ homie
how you doing man Carlos we're sharing
rules dog like that that's crazy
for real bro my just a DJ with underwear
yeah I would try to psych him out dawg I
would talk to myself and look like I'm
crazy
at that moment ready to make a decision
bro do continue the show cuz you need
the money or just drive back home yeah
for real I would ask for half of the
money right there and leave yeah when I
was just in Toledo soda I got stuck in
the snow is supposed to go to a
corporate gig and I'm stuck at the
airport for like six hours and I ended
up meeting these two girls one of them
was really sweet the other one was a
little crazy but like okay
and the people of Aspen like put me up
in the hotel again for the night because
they felt bad that I got stranded and
this one girl ended up just she went
bought a bunch of adderall bunch of coke
and she went [ __ ] insane on my ass
and I like I've seen how they like try
to get crazy with you fight you like you
know when I was a little too many uppers
and they turn into the Exorcist do you
want pity on and she's just like [ __ ]
like she just was like screaming at
everyone she was like I'm gonna [ __ ]
gas up on
and like I was like you can't stay here
it was just scary I don't know she just
got really mean and it was a bad
shrimpers I called my own so I don't
think she's gonna stab me in the next
morning my parents were like freaking
out but this girl seemed highly capable
of murderer damn
that's insane especially the drugs in
the mix you know when you get that
little look yeah the little look in the
eye and you're like oh a little twinkle
yeah she got me she got me twinkle
twitch yeah tweet but no I don't get
like offered sex or money though
sometimes people are like you want drugs
what kind of drugs yeah I know you don't
want a big Baba Suzy you wanna go stupid
when you tell them no the Terkel my
doing a different angle yeah characters
I wouldn't take that from anyone
nowadays cuz all the fentanyl [ __ ]
that's just too scary how about one of
those characters yeah alright then in
that case yeah I'll take it were in
Seattle being a STONER robber downstairs
and a dude from the show was there and
he came up to us come on we're do a shot
with you guys and there are nah nah nah
we're cool and then I was thinking if
I'll go do a shot then take off and go
to my room no no just go party with this
come on and then and there's a now we're
good oh do not got a bunch of coke am I
not even worse come on dude my lady
wants to party his lady calls and calls
his phone and his the pitcher the
profile picture of his lady on his phone
was a picture of her butthole
what do you sir right there yeah subject
it was it was a well-kept butthole here
no hair no hair like [ __ ] hair
no what happened was that I was over the
city where Wolfie will have me gone and
then Robert grabbed delay there strong
as meskan ate the one as big as that
door like a size 5 X shirt wear
flip-flops put sandals
you get those big sizes at Ross tattoos
on his face and what a party hard and
that's like that's that's they let the
hotel bar yeah yeah and then a STONER
Rob seen him the next morning are you
sure it was his wife's [ __ ] and not
just like a pretty googled one they
could've been his ass purple starfish
man oh my god Michael Jackson's clean as
a whistle did it was that button with
spit-shining
it should be a character just want to
keep partying with people because they
just want to have like a comedian at
their little party yeah
that but like very like the [ __ ]
choice yeah cuz I talk about drinking in
my act I don't want to look tired I
broke ratchet up in the morning bro yeah
and I loved putting in Morgan up
starting people but like I can only put
on so many layers of undereye before it
just doesn't do anything anymore I did
just discover luma fire I drop some of
those shits have changed my life yeah I
drop steel like 20 bucks is a lot for a
tiny bar no more fire but if you're a
man like CVS or rite-aid
luma fire they go up purple top on them
if you're high or like anything you have
to do on TV they will make your eyes
glisten like Jude Law in the holiday
this is the one that doesn't have a
white cap on top it's purple it's purple
you so check those out get them it's
worth it I remember somebody told me
about this other one that doesn't have a
certain chemical in it like Visine and
[ __ ]
oh yeah the burner is kind of a circle
octave what yeah it's alright but I mean
this sounds better
yeah man Avril stoner Rob shows up with
sweats bro sweat shorts look-alike
Disneyland's go pee just imagine like
sweat shorts just make dicks so present
like so visually present shorts yeah
uncle shorts dancing at somebody with
shorts can't help but ask me let the
right sweats I wear sweats right now
basketball ooh sweat like if you're
wearing sweats for five days in a row
people gonna see your balls your bonds
have been etched on those yeah let alone
the smell
good oppressed it's like when you run
you need like a like a bra for your
balls a yeah the bowl swimsuit like that
swimming trunk knit her Shamu bombs you
see the shadows the Impressionists
president whenever I get upgrade their
first class the Shroud of Turin I see
these fat ass fool you're talking about
with her sweat oh my man he's gonna sit
next to a some poor little lady York or
little man all those sweaty ass sweat
and then biggest do things because I sit
next to someone like Martin Rizzo they
put their arm on you I do all the time
man
oh do we're coming back on the flight is
this girl sitting next to me show so I
don't know uptight
cuz you know what they say you know you
gotta unplug you know like the the phone
yeah they take off I wasn't a plug-in
excited sometimes I don't do it but she
uh um you know you kind of plug it right
so I unplugged it and then I plug it
back in and why gets more landing
they'd set you unplug it and then I
didn't plug it and I just hear her
[ __ ] take it off and throw on the
ground pray that you're one plug plane
flown once I'd be like unplug what
that's nothing
yeah no no that's your brain making how
would that do that was that ask for
though it's clothing they got window bro
over and over a video of a guy United he
was sitting right here
I can run now he has his window right
here and the other no other no window no
one that doesn't he kept opening it and
the guy in the back kept closing here
bro over and over and I was going over
no recording attica I just sat next to a
woman on a plane and it was just me and
her a mid-sized plane and she she was
like turn off your phone oh my gosh yet
you don't work you know like I'm
listening to music yeah and she's like
turn off your phone right now and I was
like I'm not turned on my phone like
whatever and she like started yelling me
I call her flights and I was like this
woman's grassing me they moved me that's
good yeah that's my was like you're a
psycho [ __ ] have you never [ __ ]
formal and understand the airplane
like all these planes are about to fly
into each other anyways Liam plug my
[ __ ] plug and then she just drop down
the floor I think you better pick it up
before I start finger banging you with
my mind I went to uh I want to talk in
doing this and I got the beyond sausage
the big one mmm and I had and I put in
my Tupperware right so when I open it up
this fool sitting next to me
you right away cover up his nose right
in front of me in a dog to him bro
[ __ ] he were so dumb they swear
like that she we're a first class
brother first a bro you know he was mad
because I'm skinny girl was talking to
the captain about something delaying the
flight you could solve this man is
called a private jet yeah man so mad
when you when he walked when you started
falling asleep man like I knew I'm
looking over liked him Grady in a path
saw one thing I to that place where he's
asleep that's when I got up as a man to
title him bro you turn into the guy John
Candy from
I do man Planes Trains I think I'm I
know we're never I always talk to the
plate too but people can be doing that
[ __ ] to other passengers it's not your
[ __ ] plane yeah I hate it when people
don't wake me up when they have to go to
the bathroom
I was on this one flight and I like I
kept waking up like rip your kneecaps
off
he was like straddling me - I was like
sir he was standing on both of the sides
trying to like straddle jump over and I
I came to with like bulge in my face I
didn't take a little hit hey you don't
remind me - like I was on to come back
to say Santana on this weekend and I was
I don't downloaded that documentary cuz
april/may said you guys he lied in life
after porn or after poor name oh yeah
it's on Netflix so I started watching
April wait you thought about it oh yeah
yeah really I saw that older one I
hadn't seen I saw the one really and I
hadn't seen the other ones what those
are ladies - what happened so I'm
looking at it right you know I'm gonna
have my headphones on and the ladies
just elbows me I know what you're
watching I'm not yeah I'm watching a
documentary on Netflix you wanted like
are we gonna go through this or you're
gonna wait till you get home to start
acting up
oh [ __ ] oh I'm sorry I don't know what's
a documentary do you think I pull it out
right now and you start going at it
Jesus Christ
she did say nothing of at the whole
[ __ ] place she was like cheating
[ __ ] no but a couple of times a
couple ladies try to come across and
shut the window monk what are you doing
yeah I need you to close it come on no
you need to buy a ticket next to the
window yeah yeah let them know bro yeah
yeah yeah that's like an [ __ ] like
upon the moment I get in the airport and
they're my flight and I'm like if I see
you that you have a I'll see you fall
asleep with your feet out I'm going to
step on your feet
I want to kick your feet oh sorry buddy
see your feet now I thought the aisle
was open enough for everybody watch if
you'll rule to the Platinum rule 20 but
acting to defeat big bro hurts I stood
next to people bro FDC bro I feel like I
get a lot of shady looks and behavior
going through TSA pre from like white
businessmen that are like I don't think
you're supposed to be in this line honey
if I go to the airport with my hair all
dreaded and like I'm sorry Hillary today
my mom but yeah I don't like little cute
girls huh oh man
but you can't have TSA pre come on which
I thought oh people don't know they
don't understand why your tears don't
know what TSA pre and they don't know
the other one with the two fingers with
the corner clear
so you're the big who are these people
here I'm actually applying for the chief
of staff job for our president
I don't fly enough to do that but I'd be
nice to have everyone that's what
everybody's the same like people don't
travel a lot there yeah dude oh my god
crazy the person that goes on the fight
every tenure
[Music]
take off my girdle diabetic shoe my
lunch
oh my god what the [ __ ] is this [ __ ] is
dressed like Robinson Crusoe
another great multiple a way to get back
at somebody broad like and wait for them
to get their dreams and then put your
seat back and burn them with a coffee
yeah yeah when you put the seat back and
then you're like really yeah you didn't
know how much does clear cost 75 bucks
right a year and then it goes up what 75
years oh yeah what yeah we get a deal
for the first not all airports have it
yeah it's gonna be there eventually
that's what they've told you what about
the pre-check that's everywhere now
though right yeah don't have it
digitally yeah hand you a piece of paper
I know myself I get in a plane and I
start looking at people and I do
celebrity sightings and I pretend it's
someone else look is Hillary Clinton but
not Hillary Clinton yeah you know I am
from the office it's company office or
and Hulk Hogan's brother Ted ladies are
finally going home after 25 years but
what time I we were in a plane and I
said look at this [ __ ] yani late to
the player who ever say Yanni and he
said why'd you call me Yanni and it was
[Music]
every Asian gets on the plane is Martin
Reza that's so finance and then one time
it was really Martin what's up fool
Bakley Robinson will just shows the
coming up again boyfriend oh I saw you
all happy did you see the I gene I did
[ __ ] loved my wife I said I think big
about another boyfriend I'm in love with
this little Geppetto our first Christmas
your boyfriend no I've had like two of a
tutor you happy I'm just wanna say
you're glowing shining right yeah we met
inside then like a week went by we
facetimed a bunch of her thanksgiving
and then he was gonna pick me up from
the airport on Sunday and you we were
both just like why don't you just fly to
Portland and he so he came met my whole
family over the words yeah he lives in
Marina del Rey okay you like grow up
Minnesota or some [ __ ] oh honey where
the fire just like I don't know it just
like works I don't love haven't done a
background check yet I've done so backer
I asked the bride I was like she was
like before anybody calls okay before we
go before he bought his flight he let's
go through each other's flaws and like a
couple of fish were kind of like like
business interview he was like I'm a
workaholic goes like eat my ass like
that's not a yeah
you know yeah that's a worship but he's
uh yeah uh yeah I'm into him we'll see
okay but the showed a boy Thank You mr.
Robbins Geppetto on the ones and twos
December 8th Gotham New York 6 p.m.
December 17th Los Angeles UCB Franklin
December 19th through the 22nd I pray
improv with mr. Peter Lee great comic
look them up
January 16th I'm headlining Brett improv
please come to that and then January
17th 18th of B in Lincoln Nebraska at
the comedy loft also follow me on
instagram if you don't already Becky
Robinson for thank you so much
what's up fool with you part of a bunch
of Rizzo Rizzo Marco McMartin I make
more in Rizzoli yeah Rodrigo Tori's
wonderful week guys thanks for having me
oh man